et dany lang membre des économistes
atterrés étant directeur avec nous
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france en un an près
de la moitié du plan de relance de 100
milliards d'euros a été dépensé avec
quel impact selon vous sur l'économie
française
alors
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord elle se
disait votre journaliste en termes de
finances on peut pas raisonner sur
combien ça nous coûte et combien ça nous
rapporte sans réfléchir à la manière
dont seront utilisés ces dépenses et et
en particulier quand les dépenses sont
bien utilisées elles rapportent beaucoup
plus que ce que sanaa ça nous coûte donc
la vraie question
la vraie question effectivement c'est
l'utilisation et là dessus je suis assez
partagé
parce que effectivement dans ce plan de
relance il ya quand même des choses
intéressantes 30 milliards l'écologie la
transition
écologique en particulier il ya un volet
rénovation des bâtiments qui est tout à
fait louable
34 milliards la compétitivité des
entreprises et une partie sur les
investissements d'avenir on a encore il
ya des choses qui sont intéressantes et
36 milliards sur la cohésion des
territoires est totalement le
développement du numérique où le
financement du chômage partiel donc ces
dépenses là je voudrais dire qu'elles
sont non seulement nécessaires mais
elles sont indispensables
on en avait vraiment besoin revue de la
situation économique et ce sont des
dépenses ou ce qu'on appelle le
multiplicateur en économiste à lire je
mets un euro d'argent public combien je
combien j'en sors en termes de pib est
très positif donc donc on avait besoin
effectivement de dépenses dans ce
secteur par contre dans ce plan de
relance il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses qui manquent un et en particulier
on a utilisé ce plan de relance pour
faire baisser les impôts des entreprises
alors qu'on sait très bien que c'est pas
l'impôt le premier déterminants de
l'investissement c'est donc ça c'est un
peu des cadeaux sans contrepartie on n'a
pas assez insisté sur la partie demande
donc justement avec locaux vides on va
avoir besoin de relancer la demande et
en particulier la demande des ménages et
c'est un plan dans lequel il ya un tout
petit peu de relocalisation industrielle
mais où elle est complètement
insuffisante par rapport au montant du
plan donc moi je dirais que un tel plan
de 100 milliards était nécessaire c'est
peut-être même pas assez j'aimerais
contrairement à ce que dit jean castex
les allemands ni plus que nous
puisqu'ils en glissant 30 milliards de
leurs plans de relance
mais je rien mais qui soit un peu plus
centré sur
certaines activités et puis il ne faut
pas oublier non plus que avec ce plan on
a aussi fait des prêts garantis aux
entreprises et ses prêts garantis aux
entreprises ça c'est une très mauvaise
chose parce que tout simplement ça fait
augmenter la dette privée qui est la
première cause de crise économique et de
difficultés pour les entreprises ce plan
de relance est le vrai trop centré sur
quelles activités salon vaut
le plan de relance devrait être
prioritaire mans
dirigé sur l'isolation des bâtiments le
ferroutage
la relocalisation des industries dans
notre pays et la demande la demande
qui risque d'être en suffisance utilise
insuffisante il ya quand même un
d'esprit dans ce plan qui est un esprit
de l'offre en conformité avec les
orientations idéologiques du
gouvernement ça peut être intéressant
dans certains secteurs mais c'est un
plan qui néglige trop la demande à mon
sens je veux votre regard aussi sur ce
train de relance qui va parcourir toutes
les régions de france tout au tout au
long de ce mois de septembre c'est la
communication pour vous à quelques mois
et 8 mois delà de l'élection
présidentielle comment est ce que vous
voyez la chose oui monsieur du corps si
pour amuser la galerie c'est pas comme
ça
c'est pas comme ça qu'on vend un plan de
relance efficace un plan de relance
efficace et efficace quand il est bien
ciblé quand il est bien choisi quand il
est bien dimensionné effectivement 100
milliards c'est quatre fois plus que ce
qui avait été fait en 2008 donc c'est
bien et c'est aussi efficace si ensuite
à la suite de cette relance ont fait pas
le strict contraire c'est à dire si on
se remet pas serré la vis et à refaire
de l'austérité budgétaire
comme la ministre de l'économie lui-même
l'a déjà annoncé donc donc ça fonctionne
un plan de relance à condition qu'on
maintien d'efforts dans le temps à
condition qu'on le centre bien sûr des
activités prioritaires
je ne dirais pas que du mal de ce plan
de relance mais très franchement il a il
a quand même beaucoup de défauts en
particulier en terme de relocalisation
en termes d'emploi aussi parce que c'est
bien d'avoir favorisé chômage partiel
pendant la crise ce serait mieux quand
même de contribuer à la création
d'emplois de véritables emplois pour les
milliers de chômeurs
qui se sont retrouvés dans un chômage
qui n'a rien à voir une fait lyncher ni
hantise mais qui a à voir avec la baisse
de l'activité économique dans notre pays
alors justement tout dernier mot si vous
le voulez bien est-ce que cet objectif
de 6% de croissance en 2021 c'est
l'objectif du gouvernement est ce qu'il
est vraiment important demain comme
l'affirment exécutif donc ça me paraît
quand même
ça nous paraît quand même très ambitieux
varin quand on regarde les les travaux
alors je les ai pas appris par coeur je
les ai sous j'ai laisé sous les yeux les
travaux qui ont été faits par des
instituts sérieux aucun institut une
arrive
à la conclusion que ce plan de relance
permettrait d'avoir une croissance
économique de 2 6% moi ça me paraît
complètement irréaliste et d'ailleurs si
on veut des taux de croissance comme
celui là il faut mettre encore plus ce
paquet sur la transition écologique et
encore plus le paquet sur la culture
parce que dans la culture quand vous le
mettez un euro dans la culture vous avez
entre le cas lancé 25 euros de retour
sur
investissement si je puis dire donc ils
auraient une plus value centrer ce plan
sur la culture sur la transition
écologique sur la relocalisation et sur
la demande pour assurer une demande
persistant dans l'économie française
donc sur les ménages qui sont tout en
bas de l'échelle sociale merci beaucoup
pour votre décryptage des langues
membres des économistes atterrés